Film Courage: Just to go back quickly [to
what we were talking about ] so you didn’t
enter the script into any screenplay competitions,
but did you try to take it up the Hollywood
food chain with an agent or a manager?
West Liang, Actor, Screenwriter, Director:
No.
I know that Melissa [Center] sent the script
out right before production or maybe pre-production?
Just to maybe just to sort of see what the
feedback was and we had various comments about
the script and I was able to weigh what comments
helped us and what didn’t.
I think again going back to what a real, realistic
kind of road map for this trip that we would
be taking, it was really about that.
Because a lot of people came back with notes
about well that thing should really be happening
on page 12 not 7.
“Hey, that thing there doesn’t make sense.”
And I think a lot of the comments like that
are well-meaning because I’ve written for
many, many years and I think I understand
all of that stuff.
But the conversation that I had with Melissa
that I had to really negotiate was this project
is really about a certain location, a certain
budget, a certain kind of vision in terms
of scheduling.
And so we really had to be wise in terms of
what feedback we wanted to take and what feedback
we wanted to dismiss.
So we didn’t take it up the Hollywood food
chain (so to speak).
They probably won’t be interested because
there is no car chase or no aliens or anything
like that.
It was really kind of a personal thing that
we wanted to embark on.
Film Courage: Did you implement any changes
into the script though?
When they said, “This is confusing here”
or maybe they didn’t say that.
Did the two of you say “Well, if we’re
getting feedback from an outside source, maybe
we’re so close to it?”
West Liang: Absolutely.
I mean Melissa and I worked on outlining this
story from the very beginning, really trying
to talk about the characters, talk about the
relationship, talk about the plots, the narrative
(all of that stuff), and themes and everything.
And then once we had a pretty fair idea of
what story we wanted to tell, I went away
and wrote the script because I was going to
end up directing it and I felt that it was
really important to be intimately involved
with the nuts and bolts of it.
And then once we got people kind of looking
at the script, we absolutely took in advice
and comments about it.
If that button is not funny enough or that
is an extra scene that you really don’t
need, we absolutely did that.
And also (like with all films), you essentially
rewrite the script in editing, you’re writing
your final draft in editing.
And we had an amazing editor on board who
really works on bigger budgeted movies but
he liked the story (he believed in it).
And so me, Melissa and Derek during editing
really kind of tried to reshape the story
in some ways to match what we wanted to do
because there were still scenes that we ended
up not getting to even with the intention
of shooting a short script, we still missed
scenes.
Film Courage: Why?
(Sorry to interrupt)
West Liang: Well, because of budget, because
of time, because of schedule.
It’s an ensemble film so you’re working
with the schedules of so many people.
And there’s the budget part of it which
is like running out of time (that’s going
to take an extra day).
So that put us in…I mean it wasn’t a horrible
situation, it ended up being even better.
But I do think that all of the feedback that
you have to take all the way from the beginning
to the very end, even in editing we went through
three or four different cuts before we arrived
at the final cut.
And throughout the process we had a very private
kind of screening for about ten people on
the big screen and we did kind of a Q&A (feedback).
We gave them questionnaires and we said what
part of the movie did you enjoy?
What do you think about when you’re done
watching this movie?
And this questions and the answers to those
questions really helped us gauge how far off
we were about our movie.
Film Courage: Going back to what you said
earlier, the best solution or answer usually
wins in your opinion (something like that),
do you think a lot of people are that open?
West Liang: I mean…no.
I don’t think so.
I think even in some ways, I missed a mark
because with art, you have to have an ego
in your story.
I don’t think the ego should get in the
way but I do think you have to have an idea
of what your personal conviction is, what
your vision is.
So I think being mindful of it is healthier
than I think a lot of people are.
And I’d like to believe that I can always
take a good note.
It doesn’t always happen and I think it’s
true for everyone who is working in this industry,
you have to walk that line of what do you
personally feel like is right and what the
feedback is from different people.
So it’s a tough thing to kind of negotiate.
I think you have to look at it in the context
of where the person is coming from.
I’m coming from another project that is
very similar so I have a certain perspective
and someone else is coming from something
else and so you have to measure all of that.
Film Courage: And have a filter in terms of
what is exactly constructive criticism and
what is someone just B.S.ing me and what is
someone trying to squash me.
West Liang: Right.
Film Courage: And I think that’s a tough
thing because in LA or anything creative,
there are all of those things coming at you.
West Liang: Right.
Film Courage: And I think anybody who does
something creative has a fairly strong ego
and you can’t a be mouse either.
You can’t be like “Oh, okay?
Let me change that for you.”
You have to fight back a little bit.
West Liang: Absolutely.